Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. And this time last year, we were doing an anniversary episode on 1922, the year that some historians have described as the year that modernity began. And this year, Dominic, marks another anniversary, but an altogether darker anniversary, the 90th anniversary of the coming to power in January 1933 of the Nazis, when Hitler became Chancellor. And so we thought that we can't really do justice to the rise of the Nazis in one episode.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客福利、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。就在去年的这个时候，我们做了一期关于 1922 年的周年纪念节目。1922 年被一些历史学家描述为现代性开端的年份。多米尼克，今年迎来了另一个周年纪念，但这是一个完全更加黑暗的周年纪念——1933 年 1 月纳粹上台，希特勒成为总理的 90 周年。所以我们觉得，我们无法在一期节目中真正公正地评述纳粹的崛起。
So we're going to, well, we'll see how many episodes it takes, but it's a story worth telling. I mean, it is a massive, massive story, isn't it? It is. It's an enormous story. So yes, you're absolutely right, Tom. It's 90 years ago, the 30th of January, 1933, about half past 11 at the Reich Chancellery at Wilhelmstrasse 77 in Berlin. So the Reich President's Palace was being renovated. So Paul von Hindenburg, the iconic general of the Great War in Germany, he was the president. And he welcomes the leader of the National Socialist Party, Adolf Hitler, to become Chancellor of Germany. Hitler swears an oath to uphold the Constitution, to respect the role of the president. He says he will.
所以我们将，嗯，我们会看需要多少期节目，但这绝对是一个值得讲述的故事。我的意思是，这是一个宏大无比的故事，对吧？确实如此。这是一个极其宏大的故事。所以是的，汤姆，你完全说得对。那是 90 年前，1933 年 1 月 30 日，大约 11 点半，在柏林威廉大街 77 号的帝国总理府。当时帝国总统府正在翻修。因此，德国一战的标志性将军保罗·冯·兴登堡，他是总统，他迎来了国家社会主义党（纳粹党）领袖阿道夫·希特勒，出任德国总理。希特勒宣誓维护宪法，尊重总统的职责。他说他会做到的。
These are extraordinary times, but he's determined to bring back normal parliamentary rule as soon as possible. And then the deal is done. And Hindenburg says famously, a now gentleman forwards with God. And that meeting, that moment has gone down as a very baleful landmark in human history. Obviously, the communists have come to power in Russia, but the coming to power of the Nazis in Germany seems to cast an even darker shadow. And one of the reasons for that, you might say, is implicit in the scene that you've just described, which is that the Nazis, unlike the Bolsheviks, they come to power by means of gaining mass support in free elections. And that perhaps is why it so haunts people in
这是一个不同寻常的时期，但他决心尽快恢复正常的议会统治。然后交易就此达成。兴登堡说了那句名言：“先生们，带着上帝向前吧。”那次会议、那个时刻作为人类历史上一个非常不祥的地标而被载入史册。显然，共产党人在俄国夺取了政权，但纳粹在德国的上台似乎投下了更阴暗的阴影。你可以说，其中一个原因就隐含在你刚才描述的场景中，那就是纳粹不像布尔什维克，他们是通过在自由选举中获得群众支持而上台的。这也许就是为什么它至今仍让民主国家的人们如此挥之不去。
democracies to this day, that something could have happened like that. Because the other aspect of the story that is so unsettling is that this is happening in perhaps the most cultured, economically advanced, industrially advanced, sophisticated country in the whole of Europe, Germany. Yeah. So those two questions, how is it that the Nazis are able to use democracy to destroy itself and how did a country like Germany come to fall under the spell of a man like Hitler both of them very very frightening questions right the way into the present they are absolutely so we've just done haven't we, two podcasts about Auschwitz with Jonathan Friedland, about the story of the escape artist, the man who escaped from Auschwitz.
因为这件事可能会发生。因为这个故事另一个令人感到不安的方面是，这发生在整个欧洲文化水平最高、经济最发达、工业最发达、最成熟的国家——德国。是的。所以这两个问题是：为什么纳粹能够利用民主来摧毁民主？以及像德国这样的国家怎么会落入希特勒这样的人的魔咒？这两个都是从现在一直延续到未来的、非常非常可怕的问题。它们绝对是。所以我们刚刚做过了，对吧？与乔纳森·弗里德兰（Jonathan Friedland）一起制作了两期关于奥斯威辛集中营的播客，讲述逃生大师的故事，那个从奥斯威辛逃出来的人的故事。
So we know where the story is heading. And I think you're absolutely right that there are those two elements to the sort of mystery, as it were, a really crucial one that the Nazis didn't seize power. I mean, they didn't quite win power by electoral means because they never won an absolute majority in a free and fair election, but they were the biggest party. Yeah. And they're engaging in the kind of horse trading that is standard. Absolutely standard. Liberal Democrat behavior. Yeah. I mean, absolutely. They get into power by, as it were, constitutional means. Now, obviously, there are lots of gray areas and there's lots of violence that accompanies that. But you're right. It's not a coup. It's not a revolution as it were, constitutional means. Now, obviously, there are lots of gray areas, and there's lots of violence that accompanies that. But you're right, it's not a coup, it's not a revolution as it is with the Bolsheviks in 1917. So there's that element to it. As you
所以我们知道故事的走向。我认为你完全说得对，这个“谜团”实际上有两个要素：一个至关重要的问题是，纳粹并没有夺取政权。我的意思是，他们并不是通过选举手段完全赢得政权的，因为他们在自由公正的选举中从未赢得过绝对多数，但他们是最大的党派。是的。而且他们正在进行那种标准的政治交易。绝对是标准行为。自由民主党的行为。是的。我的意思是，完全是这样。他们是通过某种宪政手段上台的。现在，很明显，这里有很多灰色地带，伴随着大量的暴力。但你是对的。这不是政变。它不像布尔什维克在 1917 年那样是一场革命，它是通过宪政手段进行的。当然，这里有很多灰色地带，并伴随着大量的暴力。但你是对的，它不是政变，也不是像布尔什维克在 1917 年那样的革命。所以，它有这样一方面。正如你
said, using democracy against itself. And then I think you're absolutely right. It's the fact that Germany is an immensely well-educated, sophisticated, civilized, in inverted commas, place. And ever since, I think, I know you think this too, Tom, that we have lived in the shadow of the Third Reich. Because always, for any Western democracy, that fear never goes away. That, you know, you're only a few steps away from heading down the same dark road and how can you put i mean you've seen this so much of course in the last few years people worried about how could it happen again could it happen in france could it happen in the united states could it happen in britain and what does it say about human nature and about modernity
所说，利用民主来对抗民主本身。然后我认为你绝对说得对。事实是，德国是一个受过极好教育、成熟、文明（加引号）的地方。从那以后，我认为，我知道你也这么认为，汤姆，我们一直生活在第三帝国的阴影之下。因为对于任何西方民主国家来说，这种恐惧永远不会消失。那就是，你知道的，你离走上同一条黑暗道路只有几步之遥，你该如何解释呢？我的意思是，你在过去几年里当然也经常看到这一点：人们担心这怎么会再次发生？它会发生在法国吗？它会发生在美利坚合众国吗？它会发生在英国吗？一个这样的政权能够存在，这说明了人性和现代性本身什么？
itself that such a regime was able to possibly possibly about do the causes do the roots lie deeper back so obviously the moral catastrophe of nazism which has as you said culminate i mean you know the the dark heart of it are those two episodes that we on auschwchwitz, genocide, I mean, the mass, mass killing. Yeah. Where could this have come from? Yes. And people have been asking that, and they were asking it pretty early on. And there are all kinds of, I mean, we can just sort of touch on the different explanations that people have had.
可能，这背后的原因、根源是否更深远呢？显然，纳粹主义的道德灾难——正如你所说，达到了高潮，我的意思是，其黑暗核心就是我们制作的关于奥斯威辛和种族灭绝的两期节目，也就是大规模的大屠杀。是的。这可能是从哪里来的呢？是的。人们一直在问这个问题，而且他们很早就开始问了。各种各样的人——我的意思是，我们可以简单地探讨一下人们曾有过的各种解释。
So there are some German historians who argued that it was unique to Germany, that Germany had always been on a special path, the Sonderweg thesis, this is called. So the idea that Germany didn't modernize properly, that it didn't have a kind of bourgeois politics like Britain and France, that it was more reactionary, that it was more militaristic, that it was special, and that Nazism was uniquely German. I don't actually think many historians still believe that, Tom. There are people who believe that Nazism was prefigured by the Kaiser's regime, by the First World War. So there's a very famous German historian called Fritz Fischer. He basically argued that Germany's war aims in 1914 were paving the way for the Third Reich, and there was a kind of
有些德国历史学家认为这是德国独有的，德国一直走在一条特殊的道路上，这就是所谓的“特殊道路”（Sonderweg）论。这种观点认为，德国没有实现彻底的现代化，它没有像英国和法国那样拥有资产阶级政治，它更加反动，更加军国主义，它是特殊的，纳粹主义是德国独有的。实际上，我认为现在没有多少历史学家还相信这一点了，汤姆。有些人认为纳粹主义是由威廉二世政权和第一次世界大战预示的。因此，有一位非常著名的德国历史学家名叫弗里茨·费舍尔（Fritz Fischer）。他基本上认为，德国在 1914 年的战争目标为第三帝国铺平了道路，德国历史具有某种
continuity in German history. Again, I'm not entirely sure about that. There was a historian called Friedrich Meinecker. Again, he said that he blamed Bismarck. He said there's a line that runs from Bismarck and the Second Reich, so the creation of a unified germany in 1870 71 um that that leads to hitler obviously if you're a marxist if you're a really card carrying old-fashioned marxist you would say it's all about um a product of the sort of the dynamics of class struggle and that's one that's contemporary to hitler isn't it so a lot of communists think so brecht and famously in his place it advances the thesis that hitler is brought to power by big business. Exactly, that they're tools of big business.
连续性。同样，我对此并不是完全确信。有一位历史学家名叫弗里德里希·迈内克（Friedrich Meinecke）。同样，他将责任归咎于俾斯麦。他说，从俾斯麦和第二帝国——即 1870-1871 年统一德国的建立——存在一条通往希特勒的脉络。很明显，如果你是一个马克思主义者，如果你是一个真正正统的老派马克思主义者，你会说这一切都是关于阶级斗争动态的产物，这与希特勒是同时代的，对吧？所以很多共产党人都是这么认为的，比如布莱希特，他在他的剧作中著名地提出了这样一种论点：希特勒是由大资本扶植上台的。没错，他们是大资本的工具。
Again, I don't think that's one that a lot of historians would really subscribe to now. So the great British historian of the Third Reich, Richard Evans, who is very much a historian of the left, he's pretty scathing about that thesis in the first volume of his great trilogy on the Third Reich. Probably the most famous Briton ever to write about hitler is ajp taylor i mean ajp taylor appalled people this was when he was churning out incredibly um provocative columns for the sunday express in the sort of 50s and 60s oh thank god that um historians don't write for provocative columns for tabloids today. Tabloid is the wrong word, so I think mid-market newspaper is the correct term.
同样，我认为现在很多历史学家不会真正认同这一点。因此，第三帝国的伟大英国历史学家理查德·埃文斯（Richard Evans），他非常倾向于左翼历史学，他在其关于第三帝国的伟大三部曲的第一卷中，对这种论点进行了相当严厉的批判。写希特勒的最著名的英国人可能要数 A.J.P. 泰勒（A.J.P. Taylor）了。我的意思是，A.J.P. 泰勒曾让人震惊，当时他在 50 和 60 年代为《星期日快报》撰写极其具有挑衅性的专栏文章。哦，谢天谢地，历史学家今天不再为小报撰写挑衅性专栏了。“小报”这个词用错了，所以我认为“中端市场报纸”是正确的说法。
Thank you for correcting me. So A.J.P. Taylor said that Hitler was a normal German leader, that there was nothing unusual about Hitler. Nazism, said Taylor, represented the deepest wishes of the German people. Now, again, I think a lot of people now would say A.J.P. Taylor was almost being deliberately offensive with that. And that, yes, there is something peculiarly German about Nazism, but Taylor was completely ignoring the fact that Germany had all these tradition, democratic and liberal traditions, as well as more reactionary ones. But Dominic, also on the theme of centuries of, you know, this has been centuries and centuries in the making, you would not expect me to let a possible mention of Christianity slip by. I would not.
谢谢你的纠正。因此，A.J.P. 泰勒说，希特勒是一个正常的德国领导人，希特勒身上没有什么不寻常的地方。泰勒说，纳粹主义代表了德国人民最深层的愿望。现在，同样地，我想现在很多人会说，A.J.P. 泰勒那样说几乎是故意冒犯。而且，是的，纳粹主义确实有某种独特的德国特色，但泰勒完全忽视了这样一个事实：德国拥有所有这些传统、民主和自由的传统，以及更多的反动传统。但是多米尼克，同样围绕着“几个世纪的积淀”这个主题——你知道，这是经过了几个世纪的演变——你不会指望我放过任何可能提及基督教的机会吧。我当然不会。
There is also the thesis that the Holocaust is bred by centuries and centuries of Christian antisemitism. Yes. And, you know, the kind of folkloric belief in Jews as the enemies of Christ, that this is the kind of fertilizing the hatred that will be watered by Hitler. Yeah, and there must be some element of truth in that, Tom, that somewhere when you're analyzing the ingredients that lead to the death camps, the weight of history has to play a part,
还有一种观点认为，大屠杀是由几个世纪以来的基督教反犹太主义孕育出来的。是的。而且，你知道，那种将犹太人视为基督敌人的民间信仰，这就是给仇恨施肥，而这仇恨将由希特勒来浇灌。是的，其中一定有某种真实的成分，汤姆。当你分析导致死亡集中营的各种因素时，历史的份量必须发挥作用，
hasn't it? Although, as we will see, the quality of modern antisemitism is racial rather than religious but but but i agree i think it is you know that is a fact it must be also i'm sure we'll know if you were picking a country in 1900 where a holocaust might happen germany probably wouldn't have been top of the list russia france might have been even as antisemitism is probably more virulent in france in some ways with the drafus Anyway, we're sort of jumping ahead of ourselves. So there's always that tension. Is Nazism uniquely German? Is it uniquely European? Is it about something to do with modernity? Or if you were stepping right back, does it speak to something very dark in
不是吗？尽管正如我们将看到的，现代反犹太主义的本质是种族性的，而不是宗教性的。但但但我也同意，我认为这是一个事实，它必定是。另外，我敢肯定我们也知道，如果你在 1900 年挑选一个可能会发生大屠杀的国家，德国可能不会排在榜首。俄国、法国可能都会。甚至在某种程度上，法国的反犹太主义可能更强烈，德雷福斯事件就是证明。总之，我们有点言之过早了。所以这种张力总是存在的：纳粹主义是德国特有的吗？它是欧洲特有的吗？它与现代性有关吗？或者退一步讲，它是否说明了人性中非常黑暗的东西？
human nature? Well, so isn't there also the question of, is it bred of material circumstances? So a kind of economic collapse, the hyperinflation, the Great Depression, all that kind of a bit of both, that it's economic crisis amplifies extremist opinions. I think, yes, I think you're right. I think that's a fascinating tension, isn't it? Because I know generally in this podcast, I tend to be Mr. Material and you're much more interested in ideas than I am. So we'll probably, well, we'll tease a lot of this out, I guess. So should we start by talking about, maybe we'll tease a lot of this out, I guess. So should we start by talking about, maybe we'll start by talking about Germany. Yes. Okay. So how far back would you trace the origins of Nazism? Would you trace it back to medieval antisemitism? Would you trace
那么，难道没有关于它是否孕育自物质环境的问题吗？比如经济崩溃、恶性通货膨胀、大萧条等等，这是一种“兼而有之”的观点，即经济危机放大了极端主义观点。我认为，是的，我想你是对的。我认为这是一种迷人的张力，对吧？因为我知道在这个播客里，我往往倾向于做物质主义先生，而你比我更对思想感兴趣。所以我们可能会，嗯，我们大概会把很多这些东西梳理清楚，我想。那么，我们应该从讨论开始吗？也许我们会梳理出很多东西，我想。那么，我们应该从讨论开始吗？也许我们可以从讨论德国开始。是的。好的。那么，你会把纳粹主义的起源追溯到多远以前？你会把它追溯到中世纪的反犹太主义吗？你会把它追溯到
it back to Luther? Would you trace it back to Frederick the Great? Would you trace it back to Bismarck? Well, Richard Evans, who I mentioned already in his magnificent books on the Third Reich, he begins by saying something like, does it make sense to start with Bismarck? And he thinks it does. And I think, in a sense, you're right, because there's only really one lifetime, not even one lifetime that separates Bismarck founding the German Empire in 1871, and the coming to power of the Nazis at the beginning of the 1930s. So it kind of, you know, since somebody could plausibly see both, it makes sense to use that as a span.
路德吗？你会把它追溯到腓特烈大帝吗？你会把它追溯到俾斯麦吗？好吧，理查德·埃文斯——我刚才在他的关于第三帝国的宏伟著作中提到过他——他开篇就说，从俾斯麦开始有意义吗？他认为是有意义的。而且我认为，在某种意义上你是对的，因为真正隔开俾斯麦在 1871 年建立德意志帝国与 1930 年代初纳粹上台的，只有一个生命周期，甚至连一个生命周期都不到。所以，既然有人可以合乎逻辑地亲历这两者，那么以此作为一个时间跨度是有道理的。
So Germany didn't exist before 1871. I mean, there's a concept of Germany and there are people who speak German and there's a sense of German culture and German literature and German history, but there's no state. Which would include Austria. We should put that out. Yes. So Austria will play a part in this because, of course, Hitler is Austrian,
所以德国在 1871 年之前并不存在。我的意思是，存在“德国”这个概念，有说德语的人，有德国文化、德国文学和德国历史的概念，但没有这样一个国家。其中将包括奥地利。我们应该指出这一点。是的。所以奥地利将在其中扮演一个角色，因为当然，希特勒是奥地利人，
but Austria is shut out of the creation of Germany or the Germans in Austria because they're part of the Habsburg Empire. There are definitely elements in – so Bismarck is the great guiding spirit of this new German empire that's created when they beat the French in 1871. And there are definitely elements in Bismarck's creation, the Second Reich. We did a whole podcast about this with Katja Hoyer back in the early days of the rest of history, that prefigure Nazism. So Bismarck believes in force to get his way. Well, famously, yeah, blood and iron is the famous phrase that he uses, isn't it?
但奥地利被排除在德国的创建之外，或者说奥地利德意志人被排除在外，因为他们是哈布斯堡帝国的一部分。在俾斯麦创建的这个新德意志帝国中，绝对存在着一些因素——俾斯麦是这个新德意志帝国的伟大指导精神，这个帝国是在 1871 年他们击败法国人时建立的。在俾斯麦创造的第二帝国中，绝对存在着预示纳粹主义的元素。早在《历史的余烬》早期，我们就和卡蒂娅·霍伊尔（Katja Hoyer）一起做了一整期关于这个主题的播客。俾斯麦相信用武力来达到目的。嗯，著名的，是的，“铁血”是他使用的著名短语，不是吗？
I don't think that makes him unusual in 19th century Europe at all. He's very ruthless and subtle. But it is specifically that he's talking about how the great questions of the day should not be decided by speeches and all that kind of stuff. That essentially, you know, I buy on and blood. He basically means the military, doesn't he? He doesn't,
我不认为这使他在 19th 世纪的欧洲显得多么不同寻常。他非常冷酷无情且精明。但具体来说，他是在谈论当代的重大问题不应该通过演讲之类的方式来决定。本质上，你知道，“我买肉和血”（译者注：原文 i buy on and blood 谐音自 Bismarck 的 "Iron and Blood"）。他基本上是指军队，不是吗？他不是，
but he, I mean, it works. He gets, he fights at three wars against the Danes, against the Austrians and then against the French. But that is a contrast say with Britain. I mean, it's a very obvious question.
但他——我的意思是，这管用。他打赢了三场战争——对丹麦、对奥地利，然后对法国。但这与英国形成了鲜明对比。我的意思是，这是一个非常显而易见的问题。
Britain is already, well, Britain is fighting wars abroad. Yeah. I mean, a lot of people would say, come on, you know,
英国已经在，嗯，英国正在海外打仗。是的。我的意思是，很多人会说，得了吧，
the British are fighting their wars in the Sudan or Egypt or whatever. But Bismarck is enshrining a political role for the army. Agreed. And the army obviously is a tool of force. So it could be argued that the idea that force and violence are acceptable expressions of political will are kind of soldered into the German constitution. They are. I mean, I don't know if that's valid but i think a lot of people historians would agree with you about that tom and they would say the
英国人正在苏丹或埃及或其他地方打仗。但俾斯麦为军队确立了政治角色。同意。而且军队显然是武力的工具。因此可以说，武力和暴力是可以接受的政治意志表达方式这一理念，已经焊接进了德国宪法中。确实如此。我的意思是，我不知道这是否有效，但我认为很多历史学家会同意你关于汤姆的看法，他们会说
the army is enshrined within brismarck's second reich it's kind of like a state within a state it's self-governing it answers only to the kaiser it doesn't answer to civilian politicians because isn't that there's kind of the um the joke is that politicians in the Second Reich are constantly threatened from a coup above? That if they go too far, they know that the generals and the Kaiser will dump on them. Well, this is exactly what will happen, actually, Tom. This is the shadow that hangs over the Weimar Republic later on in the years before the Nazis come to power. You have the big man, so initially the Kaiser and then President Hindenburg in the 1920s with the army, and that they're actually often working against the democratically elected
军队被铭刻在俾斯麦的第二帝国之中。它有点像国中之国，是自治的，只对威廉二世皇帝负责，不对文官政治家负责。因为这其中是不是有一种，呃，笑话是第二帝国的政治家们不断受到来自上层的政变威胁？如果他们走得太远，他们知道将领们和皇帝会抛弃他们。好吧，这正是后来会发生的事情，实际上，汤姆。这就是在纳粹上台之前的那些年里，悬在魏玛共和国头上的阴影。你拥有大人物，最初是皇帝，然后是 1920 年代的总统兴登堡和军队，他们实际上经常与民主选举产生的
politicians. So there's that. There's the idea of a kind of Germandom, that all German speakers have a destiny to be united in a single empire, a Reich. So that's obviously there in the late 19th century. There is the experience of imperialism, the colonial experience. The Germans, if you were defending the Germans, you would say learning from other European countries' example where they behave with great ruthlessness and bloodthirstiness, for example, in southwest Africa where they massacre the Herero population. There's an anxiety about Bismarck's Second Reich.
政治家作对。所以有这一点。还有“德意志精神”的概念，即所有德意志语使用者都有命运被统一在一个单一帝国（即“帝国/Reich”）中的命运。所以这显然在 19th 世纪末就存在了。还有帝国主义的经验，殖民经验。德国人——如果你在为德国人辩护的话——会说，他们是在向其他欧洲国家的榜样学习，在那些国家表现得非常冷酷和嗜血，例如在西南非洲，他们大屠杀赫雷罗人。人们对俾斯麦的第二帝国感到一种焦虑。
So there's a sense that they have been, they're latecomers, aren't they, to the European party. They're a new state welded together, as you said, by iron and blood. And there's a sense that the British and the French in particular have had centuries head start. And I've got all these colonies and all these advantages and the Germans are catching up and feel a little bit resentful about it. That said, Bismarck is clearly not a Nazi. He is reactionary, undoubtedly, but then there are lots of reactionary, I mean, Lord Salisbury is a reactionary. There are lots of reactionary politicians in Europe. But also, there are lots of militaristic politicians. We've emphasised the militaristic character of the Second Reich, but it is also very democratic.
所以有一种感觉，他们是后来者，对吧？他们是欧洲派对的迟到者。他们是一个通过“铁血”焊接在一起的新国家。并且有一种感觉，英国人和法国人特别是占有了几个世纪的领先优势。而且我拥有所有这些殖民话语和优势，而德国人正在迎头赶上，并对此感到有些怨恨。话虽如此，俾斯麦显然不是纳粹。他毫无疑问是反动派，但当时有很多反动派——我的意思是，索尔兹伯里勋爵就是一个反动派。欧洲有很多反动政治家。而且，也有很多军国主义政治家。我们强调了第二帝国的军国主义特征，但它也非常民主。
And in lots of ways, it is more democratic than Britain. Yes, it is. Absolutely. A much larger franchise. It has a much larger franchise. Exactly right. Much larger trade union movement. I suppose what you would say, again, if you're looking with the benefits of hindsight, you
而且在许多方面，它比英国更民主。是的，确实如此。拥有更广泛的选举权。它拥有更广泛的选举权。完全正确。规模大得多的工会运动。我想你会说，如果你带着后见之明的优势来看，你会
would say they have this huge party, the Social Democratic Party, kind of a left wing party. It's the largest party in the world, right? Yeah, a million members, the largest democratic party in the world. And yet there's always this sense in Bismarck, in the state that Bismarck has created, that they're not really legitimate, that there's always this suspicion of them, this idea that the conservative middle classes are terrified of them, they say that they are Marxists. Well, they are Marxists. That they are a threat to the
说他们拥有这个庞大的政党——社会民主党，一个有点左翼的党派。它是世界上最大的政党，对吧？是的，有一百万成员，是世界上最大的民主党派。然而在俾斯麦身上，在俾斯麦创建的国家中，总是有这样一种感觉：他们并非真正合法，人们对他们总是充满怀疑，这种观点认为保守的中产阶级对他们感到恐惧，他们说他们是马克思主义者。好吧，他们确实是马克思主义者。他们是对
integrity of the Reich, that they are subversive, all this kind of thing. That said, people are saying similar things in Britain about the Labour Party, about radicals, even saying about the Liberals. Well, they are about the Labour Party. I mean, less so about the Liberals. I mean, the thing about parliamentary democracy in Britain is that you have the notion of Her Majesty's loyal opposition. You do. Which you seem to have less so in Germany, where there is on the part of the, let's call them the bourgeoisie, the bourgeois parties, the parties of the right, the parties of the middle classes, they are terrified of the
帝国完整性的威胁，他们具有颠覆性，等等诸如此类。话虽如此，人们在英国也在对工党、对激进派甚至对自由党说类似的话。好吧，他们对工党就是这么说的。对自由党则少一些。我的意思是，英国议会民主制的特点是拥有“女王陛下的忠诚反对派”的概念。确实如此。但在德国似乎没那么明显，在德国，资产阶级，我们称之为资产阶级、右翼政党、中产阶级政党的部分人，他们对
social democrats. And they never really regard them as legitimate. And so that is a theme that will feed through into the post-war period, right? Yeah, you're absolutely right, Tom. And that's a fair point. Looking back now, from post-1933, you can say they never trusted the Social Democrats. It's the biggest party, certainly the biggest party from 1912 in Germany. But among the judiciary, the police, big business, the establishment, there was always this sense, oh, they're not legitimate, we should crush them. That said, if the First World War had gone differently for Britain, then you would have looked back at Edwardian Britain, and you would have found people saying the liberals are betraying our country because of home rule, the liberals,
社会民主党感到恐惧。而且他们从不认为他们是合法的。所以这个主题将延续到战后时期，对吧？是的，你绝对说得对，汤姆。这是一个很公平的观点。现在回想起来，从 1933 年以后来看，你可以说他们从未信任过社会民主党。它是最大的政党，无疑是德国自 1912 年以来的最大政党。但在司法界、警察、大企业、建制派中，总是有这种感觉：哦，他们是不合法的，我们应该粉碎他们。话虽如此，如果第一次世界大战对英国的结局不同，那么你回首爱德华时代的英国，你就会发现有人说自由党因为自治问题在背叛我们的国家，自由党，
you know, you would have, Gladstone was a traitor, you know, they would have found people saying that. So I wonder whether there's an element of hindsight here. And I suppose also, say Britain had been defeated in the First World War or France, you would also have found, not only within the constitutional World War or France, you would also have found not only within the constitutional structure of each country, but also within the current of ideas
你知道的，你会发现有人说格莱斯顿是个叛徒，你知道，他们会发现有人这么说。所以我在想，这里是否也有后见之明的成分。我想同样地，假设英国或法国在第一次世界大战中被击败了，你也会发现，不仅在每个国家的宪政结构之内，而且在
swirling around. So that's also a part of the mix. Absolutely, it is. Yeah, you're absolutely right. So I think across Europe, not just in Germany, but across Europe, you have deep anxiety about modernity, all sorts of political and cultural and social tensions. So you see it in Britain, for example, in the Edwardian period about votes for women and all these sorts of things, about culture generally, distrust of sort of abstract culture and the new music and all that kind of thing. But in Germany, I think we can identify, let's say the 1880s and 1890s. I think a lot of historians would say Nazism is in many ways a creation of the 1880s and 1890s. You can see the ingredients. The 1880s and 1890s across Europe, intellectually, are being reconfigured by one big idea,
汹涌的思想潮流中，也存在这种情况。所以这也是其中的一部分。绝对是的。是的，你完全说得对。所以我认为在整个欧洲，不仅仅是在德国，而是在整个欧洲，人们对现代性有着深深的焦虑，存在着各种各样的政治、文化和社会紧张局势。所以你在英国也能看到这一点，例如在爱德华时代关于妇女选举权的所有这些事情，关于普遍文化的讨论，对抽象文化、新音乐以及诸如此类事情的不信任。但在德国，我认为我们可以确定，比如说 1880 年代和 1890 年代。我认为许多历史学家会说，纳粹主义在很大程度上是 18th 世纪 80 年代和 90 年代的产物。你可以看到其中的成分。1880 年代和 1890 年代的整个欧洲，在思想上正在被一个重大理念重新配置，
which is Darwinism. Yeah. And what Darwinism does is to upend the fundamentally Christian idea that the rich have a duty of care for the poor and so on, that there is a, there is a value in being, you know, in weakness,
那就是达尔文主义。是的。达尔文主义所做的是颠覆了基督教的基本理念，即富人对穷人负有照顾义务等等，即存在着一种价值，即在软弱中存在价值，
if you like, and it upends that at least the way that, that Darwinism comes to be expressed, the idea of survival of the fittest and so on. And that provides intellectual sanction for European countries across the board at their economic, their military, their cultural apex, basically to go around kicking sand in the face of anyone they want to. I think that's probably true. I think Darwinist ideas, I agree with you. I think they permeate into all kinds of different areas. The idea of competition, the idea of struggle, the idea of inevitable confrontation. And as you said, actually, Tom, I think you're probably right.
如果你愿意的话，它颠覆了这一点——至少是以达尔文主义后来被表达的那种方式，即适者生存等观念。这为欧洲各国在其经济、军事、文化顶峰时期的全面行动提供了知识上的制裁，基本上就是去向任何他们想欺负的人脸上踢沙子。我想这可能是真的。我认为达尔文主义的思想，我同意你的看法。我认为它们渗透到了各种不同的领域。竞争的观念、斗争的观念、不可避免的对抗的观念。正如你刚才所说，汤姆，我想你可能是对的。
A disdain for weakness that perhaps wasn't so strong before. And therefore, a kind of an anxiety that different peoples are in a race, and that if you drop behind, then you're going to be crushed. So I was kind of looking at this in the context of all the various themes that will feed into Nazism. And it's very kind of international so you have you have a german wilhelm marr who in 1873 is recalibrating christian anti-semitism in very overtly darwinian terms that it's not about religious prejudice it's about the fact that there are differences within the blood yeah and he absolutely so he's explicit about that it's not not religious. It's racial. It's racial. And he coins the word antisemitism.
对软弱的蔑视，这在以前可能没有这么强烈。因此，人们产生了一种焦虑，即不同的人群处于一场竞赛中，如果你落后了，你就会被粉碎。所以我一直在所有这些将融入纳粹主义的各种主题的背景下审视这一点。而且它是非常国际化的——所以你有一个德国人威廉·马尔（Wilhelm Marr），他在 1873 年以非常公开的达尔文主义术语重新校准了基督教反犹太主义，认为这关乎的不是宗教偏见，而是血液中存在差异的事实，是的，他完全是——所以他对此明确表态，这不关乎宗教。这是种族性的。是种族性的。他创造了“反犹太主义”（antisemitism）这个词。
And it's something he's tremendously proud of. And he, 1879, he founds the League of Antisemites. So that's the German angle. But then in France, also, you have, as you said, this incredible strain of antisemitism. And it's in France that thinkers coined the idea of the Aryans as a master race, the kind of people from the North as people who should properly be the rulers. I mean, it's kind of an odd thing for the French. What's his name? Gobineau. And that gets translated into German in 1898. So that's obviously also part of it. But then there is also this British figure,
他为此感到无比自豪。1879 年，他创立了“反犹太人同盟”。所以这是德国的视角。但在法国，同样，正如你所说，你拥有这种令人难以置信的反犹太主义倾向。正是在法国，思想家们创造了“雅利安人作为高等种族”的概念，即来自北方的人应该理所当然地成为统治者。我的意思是，这对于法国人来说有点奇怪。叫什么名字？戈比诺（Gobineau）。这个概念在 1898 年被翻译成德语。所以这显然也是其中的一部分。但除此之外，还有这样一个英国人物，
Houston Stuart Chamberlain, who writes this work, The Foundations of the 19th Century. And he further kind of refines this idea that history is forged by the competition between races. And he posits that the two great races, the two racial groups that have kind of retained their original purity amid all the miscegenation that's been going on, are the Aryans and the Jews. And that the Aryans and the Jews are locked, therefore, in a contest for global supremacy. And you can see how this Anglo-French-German swirl of ideas is going to feed into Nazism. But it is there. You know, it's not specific to Germany. Right. Agreed.
休斯顿·斯图尔特·张伯伦（Houston Stuart Chamberlain），他写了《十九世纪的基础》这部著作。他进一步完善了这样一种观点：历史是由种族之间的竞争锻造的。他假设，在所有正在发生的混血过程中保持了原始纯洁的两个伟大种族、两个种族群体是雅利安人和犹太人。因此，雅利安人和犹太人被锁在争夺全球霸权的竞赛中。你可以看到这种英法德思想交融将如何融入纳粹主义。但它确实存在。（这）并非德国独有。没错。同意。
Houston Stuart Chamberlain, he was an old boy of Cheltenham College, Tom. And he's drawn into this anti-Semitism because he's a passionate liberal, would you believe? So he hates Benjamin Disraeli. He has an absolute loathing of Benjamin Disraeli, who, of course, has Jewish ancestry. Interestingly, Chamberlain marries the daughter of Richard Wagner. Richard Wagner.
休斯顿·斯图尔特·张伯伦，他是切尔滕纳姆学院的老校友，汤姆。他被吸引到这种反犹太主义中，因为他是一个充满激情的自由主义者，你敢相信吗？所以他痛恨本杰明·迪斯雷利。他绝对厌恶本杰明·迪斯雷利，当然，迪斯雷利有犹太血统。有趣的是，张伯伦娶了理查德·瓦格纳的女儿。理查德·瓦格纳。
Yeah. So Wagner is a hugely interesting figure. Of course, for some people, he's tainted because of his associations with this. Other people will say, no, listen, the music is separate from the man. Sort of Wagner's shadow, his use of pseudo sort of Nordic and Germanic nationalist mythology in his operas, his intense anti-Semitism, all of that is not unique to him. It's part of that world that you've just been describing, where people are living in a world that on the one hand
是的。所以瓦格纳是一个非常有趣的人物。当然，对某些人来说，他因为与这些事物的联系而被玷污了。其他人会说，不，听着，音乐与人是分开的。某种程度上，瓦格纳的阴影，他在歌剧中使用伪北欧和日耳曼民族主义神话，他强烈的反犹太主义，所有这些都不是他独有的。它是你刚才描述的那个世界的一部分，人们生活在一个世界里，一方面
is very forward-looking, it's very scientific with all this talk of racial difference. But on the other hand it's very forward-looking with it's it's very scientific with all this talk of racial difference and but on the other hand it's backward looking steeped in history and myth and all that stuff right and that will i mean that is the great tension within fascism and nazism the way that you look back to the heroic days of you know whether it's the germans or the romans or whatever and you look forward to cutting edge science. And the way in which Germany is the scientific brand leader, that its physicians and doctors and epidemiologists have kind of identified all kinds of diseases, have tracked down kind of bacilli, all that kind of stuff. The idea that healthy organisms can be infected by germs. I mean, this provides
它是非常前瞻的，它伴随着所有关于种族差异的言论而非常科学。但另一方面，它又是非常前瞻的，伴随着所有关于种族差异的科学言论，但另一方面，它又是向后看的，浸透在历史、神话和所有这些东西中，对吧？——这意味着，这就是法西斯主义和纳粹主义内部巨大的张力，那种你回溯到英雄时代的精神（无论是日耳曼人、罗马人还是其他什么），而你又展望最前沿的科学。以及德国作为科学品牌领导者的那种方式——它的医师、医生和流行病学家已经识别出各种疾病，追踪到了各种病菌等等。健康生物会被病菌感染的观点——我的意思是，这为
a very, very potent metaphor for racists and anti-Semites. Yeah, it's fascinating, actually. The late 19th century is this period of great interest in hygiene, in the idea of social hygiene. Everything is medicalised. People are using medical metaphors all the time. And as you said, it's very easy to slip from talking about social hygiene if you're talking the 1890s or something to talking about racial hygiene so clean cities clean streets but also a clean race where the best people are breeding and and outsiders are kept out because rudolph hess i mean he he defines nazism as applied biology kind of of chilling phrase.
种族主义者和反犹太主义者提供了一个非常非常有力的隐喻。是的，实际上这很迷人。19th 世纪末是人们对卫生、社会卫生观念极感兴趣的时期。一切都被医学化了。人们一直在使用医学隐喻。正如你所说，如果你在谈论 1890 年代或类似时期，从谈论社会卫生滑向谈论种族卫生是非常容易的——所以干净的城市、干净的街道，还有干净的种族，在这里最优秀的人在繁育，而外人被排除在外。因为鲁道夫·赫斯——我的意思是，他将纳粹主义定义为“应用生物学”，真是一个令人不寒而栗的短语。
This sort of cranky science, if you like. Confirming all your darker suspicions of science, Dominic. It is. I've always... Yes, you're absolutely right, Tom. Regular listeners will know that I'm very suspicious of science generally. Yeah, so there are people talking about eugenics. There are people talking about capital punishment.
这种古怪的科学，如果你愿意的话。这证实了你对科学的所有更黑暗的怀疑，多米尼克。确实如此。我一直……是的，你完全说得对，汤姆。常听节目的听众会知道我对科学普遍持高度怀疑态度。是的，所以有人在谈论优生学。有人在谈论死刑。
Right. And eugenics, again, eugenics is absolutely you know it's not a right-wing thing it's across the political spectrum the idea that healthy societies should breed out mental physical defection defects as they see them i mean there are tons of intellectuals in britain george bennett shaw all that all that george bennett shaw lots of people who would see themselves as maybe being on the left who are saying, do you know what? We should have eugenics to breed out all these impurities.
没错。优生学，再次强调，优生学绝对是——你知道，这不是右翼的事情，它跨越了整个政治光谱——即健康的社会应该通过繁育来消除精神和身体上的缺陷（正如他们所看到的缺陷）的理念。我的意思是，英国有大量的知识分子，乔治·萧伯纳，所有那些——乔治·萧伯纳，许多认为自己可能属于左翼的人都在说：你知道吗？我们应该实行优生学来消除所有这些不纯洁的因素。
We should just execute lots more criminals, get rid of them, get them out, all of this kind of thing. There are a couple of other ideas, though, Tom, just before we move on. So one of them is this idea of pan-Germanism. So this idea that the German people must all be united in one empire, that their opponents are the Jews. So the pan-Germans, there are all sorts of pan-German movements in the 1890s, 1900s.
我们应该处决更多的罪犯，除掉他们，把他们赶出去，诸如此类的事情。不过，汤姆，在我们继续之前，还有几个其他的想法。其中之一就是泛德意志主义的概念。即德意志民族必须全部团结在一个帝国中的观点，他们的对手是犹太人。所以泛德意志主义者，在 1890 年代和 1900 年代有各种各样的泛德意志运动。
They're always looking for enemies within and without. They talk in these very sort of broad brush terms. They talk about Germandom, Jewdom, you know, Slavdom. And they think that these different domes are engaged in this apocalyptic war. A lot of pan-Germans are also interested. And here's another medical idea for you in this idea that a race needs room, needs a big living space. So this comes from an anthropologist called Ludwig Voltmann in 1900. He says the German race has evolved more than others
他们总是在寻找内部和外部的敌人。他们用这种非常宽泛的粗线条词汇交谈。他们谈论“德意志国度”（Germandom）、“犹太国度”（Jewdom）、“斯拉夫国度”（Slavdom）。他们认为这些不同的国度正在进行这场末日之战。许多泛德意志主义者也很感兴趣。这里还有另一个医学观点给你，关于一个种族需要空间、需要广阔生存空间的观点。所以这来自一位名叫路德维希·沃尔特曼（Ludwig Voltmann）的人类学家，时间是 1900 年。他说，德意志种族比其他人进化得更多，
and we need more space and that we'll have to acquire that space. It's the law of nature that we will have to acquire that space from other races. So there's all that stuff. One other element, I think, we've got time for just quickly, which is very very popular
我们需要更多的空间，我们将不得不获取这些空间。从其他种族那里获取空间是自然规律。所以所有这些东西都有。我想我们还有时间快速了解另一个元素，这个元素非常非常受欢迎
in germany and again you can see similarities with things going on in britain um is this idea of people bands of brothers these are the guys going off into mountains and hiking and singing and this is the backward looking the boy scouts it's the boy scouts in britain in germany there are all kinds of little groups of boys or young men. They'll sometimes dress up in kind of uniform type things. They'll go off hiking, communing with nature. They sit around a fire. They sing nationalist songs. They talk, but they exchange these very ideas when they're out there sitting in the hills and forests of Germany, dreaming idealistically of this utopia, this nationalist utopia that one day will come.
在德国——同样，你可以看到与英国正在发生的事情的相似之处——即“兄弟会”的人群的概念。这些是去山上远足、唱歌的人，这是向后看的童子军。它是英国的童子军。在德国，有各种各样的小男孩或年轻人群体。他们有时会穿某种制式的服装。他们去远足，与大自然交流。他们围坐在火堆旁。他们唱民族主义歌曲。他们交谈，但当他们坐在德国的山丘和森林中时，他们交换这些非常具体的想法，理想主义地梦想着这个乌托邦，这个有一天会实现的民族主义乌托邦。
But Dominic, to repeat, I mean, these are extremist ideas. By definition, they're not the mainstream. There's a lot of antisemitism on the margins. But by and large, most Germans are not obsessing about Jews. Jews are incredibly well integrated in Germany. About 1% of the population. What, 600,000, something like that? Yeah. And they're very well integrated, very assimilated, very successful, actually, professional. But that creates resentment though, Tom, I would say. So particularly when there's downturns, like in the 1870s.
但是多米尼克，重申一遍，我的意思是，这些都是极端主义观点。根据定义，它们不是主流。边缘地区有很多反犹太主义。但总体而言，大多数德国人并没有痴迷于犹太人。犹太人在德国融入得非常好。大约占人口的 1%。什么，60,0000 左右？是的。而且他们融入得很好，非常同化，实际上非常成功，是专业人士。但这会产生怨恨，汤姆，我想我会这么说。特别是当出现低迷时期时，比如在 1870 年代。
Sure. But I think, I mean, there's a case for saying, isn't there, because we know what's going to happen, historians have understandably gone back and looked for the traces of anti-Semitism in the pre-First World War world. But you can overemphasize it, I think. And so therefore, the question is, what role does the First World War play? Because all of these kind of extremist positions, I mean, they're swirling around. But had the Nazis not come to power, had the Holocaust not happened, we're swirling around. But had the Nazis not come to power, had the Holocaust not happened, we wouldn't be in, you know, historians would not be really interested in them. They're right. They'd be curious. So this is why I think the First World
当然。但我认为，这里有一个论点，不是吗？因为我们知道将会发生什么，历史学家们可以理解地回过头来寻找第一次世界大战前世界中反犹太主义的痕迹。但你可以过分夸大它，我认为。因此，问题在于，第一次世界大战扮演了什么角色？因为所有这些极端的立场——我的意思是，它们在周围盘旋。但是，如果纳粹没有上台，如果大屠杀没有发生，我们也会在周围盘旋。但是，如果纳粹没有上台，如果大屠杀没有发生，我们不会身处其中——你知道的，历史学家们不会真的对它们感兴趣。它们是对的。他们会好奇。这就是为什么我认为第一次世界大战绝对是极其巨大的。
War is absolutely colossal. Our producer is pestering us to take a break, but let's just talk for a couple more minutes about the First World War. Germany's experience of the First World War is absolutely shattering. So if you're a German in 1914, you're very conscious of living in the most modern, the most industrialized, the most forward-thinking society in Europe. And suddenly you're in this war in which the Germans, by the way, they don't think they started it. They think they are encircled and embattled by Russia and France. They blame the Russians and the French above all for the war. They think they had to get involved to support their ally, Austria. And the war is
我们的制片人一直在催促我们休息一下，但让我们再谈几分钟关于第一次世界大战的话题。德国对第一次世界大战的经历是绝对粉碎性的。所以如果你是一个 1914 年的德国人，你非常意识到自己生活在欧洲最现代、最工业化、最具前瞻性的社会中。突然之间，你卷入了这场战争，顺便说一句，德国人并不认为他们挑起了这场战争。他们认为自己被俄罗斯和法国包围并四面楚歌。他们将战争的责任主要归咎于俄国人和法国人。他们认为他们必须介入以支持他们的盟友奥地利。这场战争对
really, really tough for the Germans on the home front in the way that it isn't, let's say, for the British. So they're blockaded. The British starve them. The British are starving them. So they have famously the turnip winter in Germany, where there is just so little food, where they're drinking coffee made of dust and all this kind of thing. At that point, some people are looking for scapegoats and they're blaming the Jews. So there more than half of all the 13 million men who were mobilized. So by the end of the war, almost 2 million Germans had been killed. There are half a million widows. There are a million German children without fathers. So their world has kind of fallen apart. And also the value of the mark has collapsed.
德国后方的人民来说真的非常非常艰难，而对于英国人来说则不然。所以他们被封锁了。英国人让他们挨饿。英国人在让他们挨饿。所以在德国，他们有著名的“萝卜之冬”，那里几乎没有食物，他们喝用灰尘做成的咖啡等等诸如此类的事情。在那一点上，有些人正在寻找替罪羊，他们将责任归咎于犹太人。在那里的所有 1300 万被动员的男性中，有一半以上。所以到战争结束时，近 200 万德国人丧生。有 50 万寡妇。有 100 万没有父亲的德国儿童。所以他们的世界在某种程度上分崩离析了。而且马克的价值也崩溃了。
Yeah, so basically their currency has been inflated to pay for the war. So incredible figure that taxation only covered 14% of German government expenditure through the war. I mean, incredibly. That is incredible. Is debt and inflation, exactly. So they're kind of pauperizing themselves. And that obviously will be very important in the post-war years. Democracy has not exactly been suspended, but it's been sort of pushed to the margins because by the end of the war, the country is being run by a duumvirate of two generals, General Hindenburg, Paul von Hindenburg, and General Erich Ludendorff, who we will definitely be talking about later on.
是的，所以基本上他们的货币一直在贬值以支付战争费用。这是一个令人难以置信的数据，税收仅占德国政府战时开支的14%。我的意思是，太不可思议了。这太不可思议了。就是债务和通货膨胀，没错。所以他们有点在让自己陷入贫困。这在战后几年显然非常重要。民主并没有真正被暂停，而是被某种程度上边缘化了，因为到战争结束时，这个国家是由两位将军组成的双头政权在管理，即保罗·冯·兴登堡将军和埃里希·鲁登道夫将军，我们稍后一定会谈到他们。
So this is to keep it together. This is to kind of keep fighting. And then, to the astonished, partly because of press censorship and so on, the German people are astonished when it all falls apart in November 1918. And almost without anybody really knowing what's going on, the Kaiser is suddenly out. I mean, he's out kind of overnight. And a republic has been proclaimed in Berlin by people, many of whom did not even want a republic. So most famously, Friedrich
所以这是为了维持下去。这是为了继续战斗。然后，令（部分由于新闻审查等原因而）感到震惊的德国人民惊讶的是，这一切在1918年11月分崩离析了。几乎在没有人真正知道发生了什么的情况下，德皇突然下台了。我的意思是，他几乎一夜之间就下台了。柏林宣布成立共和国，而许多拥护者甚至一开始并不想要共和国。所以最著名的是，弗里德里希
Ebert, who's the leader of the Social Democrats, he proclaims a republic, even though he actually wanted to keep the monarchy. So the whole thing is falling apart in chaos. Berlin is racked in the winter of 1918-19 by fighting between different left-wing factions. There's rebellions, there's an uprising by a group of people called the Spartacists on the left that is put down by returning soldiers from the war. So total and utter chaos. Everything has suddenly collapsed in ruins. And ordinary Germans, particularly those who fought in the war, are completely horrified and taken unawares by this. And there's a very, very famous example, which I'll just read to you before we go into the break.
艾伯特（社会民主党领袖）宣布成立共和国，尽管他实际上想保留君主制。所以整个局势在混乱中崩塌。1918年至1919年的冬天，柏林充斥着不同左翼派别之间的战斗。有叛乱，左翼一个名为“斯巴达克同盟”的组织发动了起义，被从战场上回国的士兵镇压了。这是一场彻底的混乱。一切都在废墟中突然崩溃。普通德国人，尤其是那些参加过战争的人，对此感到无比惊恐和措手不及。这里有一个非常非常著名的例子，在我进入休息时间之前，我读给大家听。
So it's a guy who's a corporal. He's been a corporal. He's won the Iron Cross. He's well regarded by his comrades for his bravery. He's not yet 30. And he had been blinded in a gas attack near Ypres in the final weeks of the war. And he's ended up in a hospital in a place called Passauvalc in Pomerania.
所以这是一个当过下士的家伙。他一直是个下士。他获得过铁十字勋章。他因勇敢而受到战友的高度评价。他还没到30岁。他在战争最后的几个星期里，在伊普尔附近的一次毒气袭击中双目失明。最后他被送进了波美拉尼亚帕绍瓦尔克的一个医院。
And in the hospital, he's been hearing rumors of what's all going wrong. And then on the 10th of November, so literally the day before the war ends, a Protestant pastor comes to visit the hospital to give a speech to them. And he later told the story, he said, I was in a fever of excitement as I listened to the address. The Reverend old gentleman seemed to be trembling when he informed us that the house of Hohenzollern should no longer wear the imperial crown. The fatherland had become a republic, that we should pray to the almighty not to withhold his blessing, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then the pastor breaks down and he starts crying. And the soldier says, the corporal says, a feeling of profound dismay fell on the people in that assembly.
在医院里，他一直听到关于一切都出错了的传闻。然后在11月10日，也就是战争结束的前一天，一位新教牧师来到医院探望他们，并向他们发表了讲话。他后来讲述了这个故事，他说：“我在听演讲时处于一种兴奋的发烧状态。当这位年迈可敬的先生告诉我们霍亨索伦家族将不再戴着帝国皇冠时，他似乎在颤抖。祖国已经变成了共和国，我们应该向全能者祈祷不要收回他的祝福，等等，等等。”接着，牧师情绪崩溃，开始哭泣。那位士兵说，这位下士说：“一种深度的沮丧感落在了那个集会的人群身上。”
And I do not think there was a single eye that withheld its tears as for myself i broke down completely when the old gentleman tried to resume his story by informing us that we must now end this long war because the war was lost and we were at the mercy of the victor it was impossible for me to stay and listen any longer darkness surrounded me as i staggered and stumbled back to my ward and I buried my aching head between the blankets and the pillow. I had not cried since the day I stood beside my mother's grave. And Dominic, the name of that corporal, what was it? It was, of course, Tom, Adolf Hitler. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我想没有哪双眼睛能忍住不流泪。至于我自己，当这位老先生试图恢复他的故事，告诉我们我们现在必须结束这场长期的战争，因为战争已经失败，我们任由胜利者摆布时，我彻底崩溃了。我再也无法待下去听下去了。当我摇摇晃晃、跌跌撞撞地回到病房时，黑暗包围了我，我把疼痛的头埋在毯子和枕头之间。自从我站在母亲墓碑旁的的那天起，我就没有哭过。多米尼克，那个下士的名字是什么？当然是，汤姆，阿道夫·希特勒。休息一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余全是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告版、独家番外节目并提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，那是
therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the rise to power of the Nazis. And Dominic, just before the break, you introduced Adolf Hitler having a, well, basically losing it over germany having been defeated um yeah breaking down and sobbing like a baby beside his mother's grave so we did an episode we did two episodes on hitler didn't we on the life of hitler with um sir ian kershaw but just give us a brief reminder for those who didn't listen to that and who may not know about hitler's background where does he come from so hitler is austrian and i And I think a Syrian would undoubtedly say, the salient thing about Hitler is that up to this point, he is a nobody.
therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《其余全是历史》。我们正在探讨纳粹的崛起。多米尼克，就在休息前，你介绍了阿道夫·希特勒在听到德国战败时的情景——嗯，基本上是情绪失控了，呃，是的，在母亲墓旁哭得像个婴儿一样。所以我们做过一期节目，我们做了两期关于希特勒的节目，不是吗？关于希特勒生平的节目，邀请了伊恩·克肖爵士。但请为那些没有听过这期节目、可能对希特勒背景不太了解的听众简单回顾一下，他来自哪里？所以希特勒是奥地利人，而且我认为叙利亚人无疑会说，关于希特勒最显著的一点是，在此之前，他是个无名小卒。
There is nothing remarkable about him at all. He's not particularly, he doesn't appear particularly evil. He's a bit of a failure. He's just a bit of a dropout. So he was born in a place in Austria called Braunau am Inn on Easter Saturday, 1889. He's the fourth child of his Alois and Clara. So Alois' father is just a sort of slightly rubbishy kind of bad-tempered Austrian customs official. He's a civil servant, a sort of minor civil servant. So no Jewish ancestry.
他身上完全没有什么引人注目的地方。他并不是特别……他看起来也不是特别邪恶。他有点像个失败者。他只是有点像个辍学生。所以他于1889年复活节星期六出生在奥地利一个叫做因河畔布劳瑙的地方。他是阿洛伊斯和克拉拉的第四个孩子。所以阿洛伊斯的父亲只是一个有点糟糕的、脾气不好的奥地利海关官员。他是一名公务员，算是一个底层公务员。所以没有犹太血统。
No, nothing interesting. So A.N. dealt with that myth, and he also dealt with the myth that Hitler only had one ball. Tom, you love that. You love that detail, which is completely untrue. Those are the questions that the listeners will be asking, and we just want to put that down. Yeah, so the idea that there's some sort of
不，没有什么有趣的。所以A.N.处理了这个神话，他还处理了关于希特勒只有一个蛋的神话。汤姆，你很喜欢这个。你很喜欢这个完全不真实的细节。这些都是听众会问的问题，我们只是想把它澄清一下。是的，所以那种认为他有什么生理上或非同寻常的心理缺陷的想法是不对的。那是在逃避现实。我们所知道的小时候的希特勒，是一个完全正常、快乐的男孩。我的意思是，克肖在他的传记中描述了他在树林里和朋友们玩耍等等。1900年，他大约11岁时，搬到了林茨市的一所更大的学校。在那里，我的意思是，同样，这真的不是那么特别。他现在在一所大学校，地方更大，谁也不认识，
physical or extraordinary psychological flaw is not right. It's a cop-out. What we know about Hitler when he was a little boy is that he's perfectly normal and a happy boy. I mean, in Kershaw, his biography describes him playing with his friends in the woods and all this stuff. In 1900, when he's about 11, he moves to a bigger school in the city of Linz. And there, I mean, again, this is really not that exceptional. He's at a big school now, bigger place, doesn't really know anybody,
非常痛苦，有点懒惰，变得有点像个辍学生，变得郁郁寡欢、脾气暴躁。“哦，别烦我。”诸如此类的事情。是的。正如众所周知的，他告诉他的父亲：“我想去当个艺术家。”他的父亲对他大喊大叫，说绝不。只是呆在自己的房间里。
is very miserable, kind of is lazy, becomes a bit of a dropout, becomes a sort of sullen, surly. Oh, leave me alone. All that kind of stuff. Yeah. He tells his father famously, you know, I want to go and be an artist. And his father shouts at him and says never. Just hanging out in his room.
诸如此类。他的父亲于1903年突然去世。阿道夫是他母亲的掌上明珠，得以说服母亲让他辍学。然后他把时间都花在白日梦和听音乐上。但是，这也是因为这就是那回事，不是吗？
All that kind of stuff. His father drops dead in 1903. Adolf, who's the apple of his mother's eye, is able to persuade her to let him drop out of school. Then he just spends his time daydreaming and going to concerts. But also, because that's the thing, isn't it?
呆在房间里听音乐的青少年刻板印象。我的意思是，希特勒对瓦格纳着迷。绝对是。是的。我的意思是，真的很着迷。对瓦格纳完全着迷。绝对是。是的。我的意思是，真的很着迷。对瓦格纳完全着迷。你可以完全理解为什么这个脾气暴躁、相当痛苦的青少年
The stereotype of the teenager in his room listening to music. I mean, Hitler becomes obsessed by Wagner. Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, really obsessed. Completely obsessed by Wagner. Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, really obsessed. Completely obsessed by Wagner. And you can completely see why this sullen, rather miserable teenager
会痴迷于一位歌颂征服者的英雄的作曲家，你知道的，他站在敌人血淋淋的尸体上。在他的歌剧中，一次又一次地出现英雄的形象，他没有被认为是一个英雄，而是从虚无中冒出来，所以你绝对可以看出，这让你，你知道的，你能看出他是那种人，但我也认为大多数听众会说，这并不是一个特别不寻常的人。我的意思是，英国各地学校里都有这种人的多个版本，他们后来会成为理赔员、房地产经纪人、小企业顾问，你知道的，完全正常的人。
is obsessed by a composer who celebrates the hero, who conquers, you know, stands atop the bloodied bodies of his enemies. And there are so many, again and again in his operas, the figure of the hero is someone who hasn't been recognised as a hero, who kind of emerges from nowhere so you can absolutely see that a this makes it you know you can you can see the kind of person he is but you also can i think most listeners would say this is not a particularly unusual person i mean there's one in there at mon there are multiple versions of this person in schools the length and breadth of england and they will go on to become loss adjusters, estate agents, small business advisors, you know, perfectly normal people.
那么，是什么让希特勒走上了让他成为希特勒的道路呢？我想，一个至关重要的因素是他去了维也纳。因此，他的母亲于1907年去世，当时他18岁。他曾试图考入维也纳美术学院。他考了两次都没考上。对此感到非常失望。这对他是沉重的一击，因为他一直梦想成为一名艺术家。他最后成了一个落魄汉，住在男子收容所里，为游客画画，最著名的是画明信片。他在维也纳获得了一些他可能在其他地方得不到的东西。所以维也纳，当然，它很大程度上是一个讲德语的城市，但它是
So what happens to set Hitler on the path that makes him Hitler? I suppose, so one crucial thing is him going to Vienna. So his mother dies in 1907 when he's 18. He's tried to get into the Fine Arts Academy in Vienna. He doesn't get in twice. Very disappointed by that. It's a crushing blow to him because he's dreamed of being an artist. He ends up as a kind of dropout in a men's hostel, the men's home, and he's painting pictures for tourists, so postcards famously. He gets certain things from Vienna that he perhaps wouldn't have got somewhere else. So Vienna is, of course, it's a largely German-speaking city, but it is the capital of
哈布斯堡帝国的首都，也就是我们通常所说的奥地利。他把所有时间都花在听瓦格纳上。瓦格纳在维也纳非常受欢迎。但他也阅读各种书籍。维也纳有一种尤为明显的反犹太主义倾向。它是极其恶劣的，因为维也纳是一座被政治和种族冲突撕裂的城市，因为哈布斯堡帝国是多民族的。对的。因为在德国，并没有太多主流的政治反犹太主义。它只存在于边缘地带。但在维也纳，情况则不同。是的，确实如此。所以克肖在他的传记中说，你知道的，
the Habsburg Empire, what we commonly call Austria. He's spending all his time listening to Wagner. Wagner is very popular in Vienna. But he's also reading stuff. There's a kind of strain of antisemitism that's particularly pronounced in Vienna. It's particularly virulent, because Vienna is a city that is torn apart really by kind of political and racial conflict because the Habsburg Empire is multi-ethnic. Right. Because in Germany, there isn't much mainstream political anti-Semitism. It's on the edges. But in Vienna, that's different. Yeah, it is. Absolutely. So Kershaw says in his biography, you know,
当希特勒走到男子收容所外面的报摊或其他地方时，那里摆满了种族主义期刊。所以我们知道他读过一本叫《奥斯塔拉》的东西。我们认为他读过一个叫约尔格·兰茨的人写的《奥斯塔拉》，里面全是关于威胁性的、皮肤黝黑的黑发男子袭击金发女郎的内容，而且非常非常反犹太。但我知道你非常感兴趣的关键人物，汤姆，就是这个叫格奥尔格·里特尔·冯·舍内勒的人。是的，他想废除基督教历法，
when Hitler goes down to the newspaper kiosk outside the men's home or wherever, it's full of racist periodicals. So we know that he read something called Ostara. We think he read something called Ostara by a guy called Jörg Lanz, which was all about kind of menacing, dark, swarthy figures attacking blonde women, and it's very, very anti-Semitic. But the key figure, I know you're very interested in, Tom, is this guy Georg Ritter von Schönerer. Yes, he wanted to get rid of the Christian calendar,
他讨厌基督教。他想把所有的基督教节日都改成德国名字。所以，你知道的，圣诞节想改成尤勒节等等。但他还想废除基督教纪年系统，用罗马人被辛布里人和条顿人击败的日期来代替它。
and he hated Christianity. He wanted to give all the Christian festivals German names. So, you know, Christmas wanted to be Eulafest and all that kind of stuff. But he also wanted to get rid of the Christian dating system and replace it with the date of a defeat of the Romans by the Cimbri and the Teutons.
那就在马略斯之前。尼雷亚战役。这应该相当于零点，耶稣的诞辰被耶稣的诞辰所取代。尼雷亚战役。这就是全部内容。这是一种非常怪异、疯狂的事情。它体现了反犹太主义特征的那种疯狂思维倾向。是的。
So that's just before Marius. The Battle of Nerea. And that this should be the equivalent of Grand Zero, the birth of Jesus, replaced the birth of Jesus. Battle of Nerea. That's what it's all about. Which is such a kind of eccentric, mad thing. It's expressive of the kind of the strain of lunatic thinking that characterizes antisemitism. Yeah.
但舍内勒很重要，所以舍内勒是一个——他在当时的维也纳是一个相当受欢迎的思想家——因为他还提出了诸如成年男子普选权和更大的国家积极性等主张，所以很难在政治上给他的立场下定论，但他的一些思想绝对会产生很大的影响。舍内勒，例如，想把反犹太主义比其他人推得更远，在政治上。但他的一些思想绝对会产生很大的影响。舍内勒，例如，想把反犹太主义比其他人推得更远。他想把犹太人完全从生活中驱逐出去……是的，在身体上，在政治上。他也是想出“嗨伊尔”口号的人，对吧？
But Schoenera is important so schoenera is he's a he's a he's a sort of quite a popular thinker um in in vienna at the time because he's proposing also things like universal manhood suffrage and kind of greater state activism and so on so it's hard to pin down politically but some of his ideas are definitely going to be very influential schoenera for example wants to push the anti-semitism further than anybody else politically. But some of his ideas are definitely going to be very influential. Schönerer, for example, wants to push the anti-Semitism further than anybody else. He wants to remove Jews completely from the life of... Yeah, so physically, politically. And he's also the guy who comes up with the Heil, right?
是的。他的追随者称他为“元帅”，即领袖。所以你刚才提到的那些罗马风的东西，他在20世纪初的议会里开始高喊“嗨伊尔”。他的追随者，是的，他们称他为领袖。所以这种伪罗马风，你知道的，纳粹
Yeah. And his followers call him Führer, leader. So your Roman stuff that you were just mentioning, he starts shouting Heil when he's in Parliament in the early 1900s. And his followers, yeah, they call him the leader. So this sort of cod Roman, you know, the Nazis
后来会把这一切都捡起来。维也纳还有另一个关键人物，非常重要，对希特勒和纳粹主义产生了影响，那就是维也纳市长。他叫卡尔·吕格尔。同样，在政治上很难给他定性，因为他就像一个反犹太主义的维也纳版约瑟夫·张伯伦（维多利亚时代英国伯明翰伟大的市长），
are going to pick up on all that later on. There's also another key character in Vienna, very important, influenced upon Hitler and Nazism, is the mayor of Vienna. He's called Karl Luger. Again, very hard to pin down politically because he's like a sort of anti-Semitic Viennese Joseph Chamberlain, the great mayor of Birmingham in Victorian Britain,
因为他实施了所有这些伟大的市政改革。所以他真正现代化了维也纳，他为工人阶级和中下阶层做了很多事情等等。但他通过狂热而恶毒的反犹太主义赢得了支持。我们知道——所以他是个国家社会主义者咯？他是个民族社会主义者。对的。我们知道希特勒对他的男子收容所里的人说，哦，吕格尔是个了不起的人。他是德国历史上最好的市长。所以，同样，他正在吸收所有这些东西。而且他可能正在吸收，几乎可以肯定是正在吸收反犹太主义。因此，关于希特勒究竟是什么时候开始反犹太主义的，存在一些争论，但他不可能不受其影响。问题是，他的传记作家们
because he carries out all these great municipal reforms. So he really modernizes Vienna and he does stuff for the working classes and the low middle classes and so on. But he wins support by being fanatically and virulently anti-Semitic. And we know- So he's a national socialist then? He's a nationalist socialist. Right. We know that Hitler said to people in his men's hostel, oh, Luger is a brilliant man. He's the best mayor of any German in history. So again, he's picking up all of this stuff. And he's probably picking up, he's almost certainly picking up the antisemitism. So there's some debate about exactly when Hitler becomes antisemitic, but he cannot not have been influenced by it. The thing is, his biographers
认为他在那个阶段并不是病态的，因为他当时只想着他那些垃圾明信片、他的悲惨生活、瓦格纳和艺术之类的事情。显然发生在他身上的是他去参战了，因为他在过渡时期去了慕尼黑。不是有一张著名的照片吗，1914年？当然，在欢呼。他像很多人一样高兴。他真的觉得，尽管他出生在奥地利，
don't think that it's pathological at that stage stage because he's just thinking about his rubbishy postcards and how miserable he is and Wagner and art and stuff. What clearly happens to him is he goes to the war because he goes to Munich in the interim. There's the famous photo, isn't there, in 1914? Of course, cheering. He's delighted like lots of people are. He really feels like, although he's born in Austria,
他来自一个讲德语的家庭，他自己也讲德语，他觉得自己的命运在于德意志，正如他无疑会称呼的那样。所以他去参战了，我想显然发生的事情就像战争中的许多人一样，这同样不仅在德国，他被战争残酷化了，他被死亡包围着，他是一个战地信使——我的意思是，很多其他的信使都被杀了，这并不是，你知道的，比军队中的某些职位要好一些，但它依然不是一件让人开怀大笑的事。所以他对外在的死亡和痛苦变得麻木了，我认为这就是这一点，因为在那之前没有人说过“哦，希特勒热爱暴力。他是个邪恶的人。”但我想在这一点上，你知道的，他被暴力所包围。
he's from a German-speaking family he's german-speaking himself he feels like his destiny lies in a in a in germandom as he would no doubt have called it so he goes off to the war and i think what obviously happens like to a lot of people in the war and this isn't again not just in germany he's brutalized by it he's surrounded by death he's a dispatch runner i mean lots of other dispatch runners are killed it's not you know it's better than some um posts in the army um but it's still not it's not a barrel of laughs um so he's he's inured to death and to suffering i think this is the point that where yeah because before that nobody had said oh Hitler loves violence. He's an evil guy. But I think at this point, you know, he's surrounded by violence.
然后就是那种创伤感。他在帕绍瓦尔克的医院里因伤退役。我的意思是，你读到的——所以我读的那个东西，当然出自《我的奋斗》，那是他在20世纪20年代中期写的。里面有很长的段落，你知道的，“这一切都是徒劳的，牺牲是徒劳的，饥饿和口渴是徒劳的。难道士兵们在1914年8月和9月死就是为了这个吗？做这一切，难道就是为了让一群卑鄙的罪犯对祖国伸出毒手吗？”对的。我的意思是，这是强迫性的东西，所以他所指的罪犯是谁？他指的是，哦，他们被称为十一月罪犯，不是吗？那些同意停战的民主领袖，还是说他已经把犹太人称为罪犯了？两者都是，我认为这样说是公平的，我认为，呃——
And then there's that sense of trauma. And that stuff in Passerbuck in the hospital has been invalided out. I mean, you read in, so that thing that I read was, of course, from Mein Kampf, My Struggle, which he writes in the mid-1920s. And there's long passages in that, you know, it had all been in vain, in vain the sacrifices, in vain the hunger and thirst. Was it for this that the soldiers died in August and September 1914? Had all this been done to enable a gang of despicable criminals to lay hands on the fatherland? Right. I mean, this is obsessive stuff so who is he referring to as the criminals is he referring to well they're called the november criminals aren't they the democratic leaders who um agree to the armistice or is he referring to the jews already as the criminals both i think it's fair to say i think um he i mean don't forget he's writing those words
别忘了，他写这些话时已经是后来了，所以他在回顾。但当时，确有一股上升趋势——如果希特勒因为他在维也纳的经历而已经具有反犹太主义倾向，那么他在1918年仍然反犹太主义就在情理之中了。在战争的最后几年里，随着人们因为物资短缺、配给制而寻找替罪羊，反犹太主义呈上升趋势。
later so he's looking back but But at the time, there had been a rise, I mean, if Hitler was anti-Semitic already because of what he's experienced in Vienna, it makes sense that he's still anti-Semitic in 1918. There had been a rise in anti-Semitism in the last couple of years of the war as people look for scapegoats
因此人们觉得犹太人在发国难财。是的，投机商。人们在喋喋不休地谈论犹太投机商，这完全是不真实且毫无根据的。人们还在说，“哦，犹太德国人没有为战争努力尽到他们的责任。”同样，完全毫无根据。
because of the shortages, the rationing. So there's a feeling that the Jews are profiteering. Yes, speculators. People are wittering about Jewish speculators, which is completely untrue and unfounded. People are also saying, oh, the Jewish Germans aren't doing their bit for the war effort. Again, completely unfounded.
许许多多……正如墓地所证明的那样。通过提名希特勒的一个人——提名希特勒获得铁十字勋章的那个人——是一名犹太军官这一事实。但是，你知道的，人们在愤怒和沮丧时会大发雷霆。我认为这正是整个德国正在发生的事情。而且，据推测，我的意思是，希特勒对德意志、对德国人民的血统、对雅利安人民的血统有着近乎宗教般的信仰，
Many, many... As evidenced by the cemeteries. By the fact that one of the guys who had nominated Hitler, the guy who had nominated Hitler for the Iron Cross, was a Jewish officer. But, you know, people lash out when they're angry and upset. And this is what's happening, I think, across Germany. But also, presumably, I mean, Hitler has an almost religious faith in Germandom, in the blood of the German people, in the blood of the Aryan people,
然而他们却战败了。因此——而这就是那场失败的性质。因此，他解释那场失败的唯一方式就是叛国。是的，你说得对。无论是民主政客，还是更具阴谋论的观点，即德国血脉中的某种毒蛇。是的，而且失败的性质，汤姆，解释了这一点。因为你看，德国人在1918年失败，
and yet they have been defeated. So therefore- And it's the nature of that. Therefore, the only way that he can explain that defeat is by treachery. Yeah, you're right. Whether it's democratic politicians or, more sinisterly, this idea of a basilisk within the German bloodstream. Yeah, and the nature of the defeat, Tom, explains that. Because you see, Germans losing in 1918,
他们发动了如此猛烈的攻势，试图在美军真正扭转战局之前一举赢得战争。他们实际上在1918年的春夏季节取得了一切胜利，或者看起来如此。然后伟大的鲁登道夫攻势后劲不足，他们被逼退了。然后突然之间，局势非常非常快地崩溃了。并且有一种感觉，即德国人民根本没有为失败做好准备。至关重要的是，当然，当时德国本土上没有任何盟军部队。
they've gone on this tremendous offensive, attempting to win the war in one blow before the Americans can really turn the balance of the war. And they've actually carried all before them, or appeared to in the sort of spring and summer of 1918. And then the great Ludendorff offensive runs out of steam, they've been driven back. And then suddenly it collapses very, very quickly. And there's this sort of sense that the German people have not been prepared for the defeat. Crucially, of course, there are no Allied troops at that point on German soil.
所以这是一场他们输掉的客场比赛，可以说，这让他们感到惊讶，因为他们以为自己正在赢。事实上，当军队回到柏林时，我们下次会谈到的、维玛共和国创建过程中的关键人物、社会民主党领袖弗里德里希·艾伯特，对他们说了那句名言：“没有任何敌人打败了你们。”很多德国人都相信这一点。他们相信自己某种程度上失去了这场战争，但他们在军事上并没有真正被打败，
So it's an away fixture that they've lost, as it were, to their surprise because they thought they were winning. And actually when the troops return to Berlin, Friedrich Ebert, who we'll talk about next time, who's a key figure in the creation of the Weimar Republic, social democratic leader, he famously says to them, no enemy has defeated you. And a lot of Germans believe that. They believe somehow they've lost the war, but they weren't really militarily defeated,
这完全是错误的。他们在法国和比利时的土地上被击败了，但这在某种程度上被隐瞒了。所以他们说，“哦，我们被背后捅刀子了。我们被叛徒出卖了”等等。无论如何，希特勒回到了他以前待过的慕尼黑。他在1918年11月21日回来了。当时，慕尼黑已经陷入了绝对的混乱。所以当德皇政权在战争最后几天崩溃时，在整个德国，人们只是在不同的地方随机夺取了权力。在慕尼黑，权力被一个仿佛是专为了激怒希特勒而设计的人夺取了。他
which is completely wrong. They were defeated on French and Belgian soil, but it's sort of been kept from them. And so they say, well, we've been stabbed in the back. We've been betrayed by traitors and so on. Anyway, Hitler comes back to Munich, where he'd been before. He comes back on the 21st of November, 1918. And at that point, Munich is already in utter, utter chaos. So when the Kaiser's regime fell apart in the final days of the war, across Germany, people had just sort of randomly seized power in different places. In Munich, power had been seized by a man who could have been designed to provoke Hitler. He's
是一个叫库尔特·艾斯纳的人。他是一个戏剧评论家。他是一个非常波希米亚风格的咖啡馆常客，穿着一件黑色斗篷和钢丝边眼镜。他甚至不是慕尼黑人，他是柏林人，而且他是犹太人，政治倾向非常左。所以他基本上在慕尼黑建立了自己的小巴伐利亚共和国。这完全是一场混乱。右翼的所有人都说：“哦，天哪，这个犹太戏剧评论家夺取了权力，这到底是怎么回事？”他被暗杀拉。一个更加疯狂的政权上台了，即巴伐利亚苏维埃共和国，由另一个人领导，这次是一个名叫恩斯特·托勒的诗人兼剧作家。
a guy called Kurt Eisner. He's a theater critic. He's a very sort of bohemian sort of cafe habitué, wears a black cloak and steel-rimmed glasses. He's not even from Munich, he's from Berlin, and he's also Jewish, and he's very left wing. So he basically sets up his own little Bavarian Republic in Munich. It's a complete shambles. Everybody on the right says, oh my God, this Jewish theatre critic has seized power, what the hell's going on? He's assassinated. An even crazier regime comes in, the Bavarian Council Republic, under another, this time it's a poet and playwright called Ernst Toller.
他们简直荒谬绝伦。因为这其中奇怪的地方在于，当然，希特勒是一个艺术家。你拥有所有这些各种各样的剧作家、评论家之类的人物。这基本上就是报纸文艺副刊上的人，那些各种各样的剧作家、评论家之类的人，他们都在策划政变，试图建立独裁政权。你知道我的看法，汤姆，绝对不能允许任何有艺术气质的人沾手政治，呃——是的，所以恩斯特·托勒的政权——所以他们向瑞士宣战，因为瑞士没有借给他们
They're utterly ludicrous. Because that's the weird thing about this is, of course, Hitler is an artist. You have all these guys who are kind of various playwrights and critics and all that kind of stuff. It's basically people from the arts pages of newspapers, guys who are kind of various playwrights and critics and all that kind of stuff it's it's basically people from the arts pages of newspapers all staging coups trying to set up dictatorships you know my view tom artistic people should never be allowed anywhere in their politics um yeah so ernst toller's regime so what they declare war on switzerland for not lending them
60台铁路机车。他的一个部长曾发出一份著名的电报到莫斯科寻求帮助，因为他说前一个部长把部长厕所的钥匙给偷了。所以这绝对是一团糟。那个政权随后被共产党推翻了，这是一个更加强硬的共产主义政权，与莫斯科正在发生的事情保持着非常紧密的联系。他们确实认为这会吸引你，汤姆。他们的首批举措之一是将慕尼黑的一座教堂变成一座理性神庙。是的，非常，是的。
60 uh railway locomotives one of his ministers famously sends a telegram to Moscow asking for help because he says the previous minister has stolen the key to the ministerial toilet. So it's absolutely shambolic. That regime is then toppled by communists, a much more hardline communist regime, which is very much in touch with what's going on in Moscow. They do think this would appeal to you, Tom. One of their first initiatives is to turn a church in Munich into a temple of reason. Yeah, very, yeah.
非常罗伯斯庇尔式的。非常罗伯斯庇尔式的行为，是的。所以慕尼黑随后被夺回。夺回它的是一个被许多人认为在各种方面都预示了纳粹的组织。他们被称为“自由军团”。这些基本上是 returning 士兵，他们从战场上回来，其中有些人仍然不敢相信他们居然彻底战败了，而这些人也是在柏林镇压共产主义者的人，正是如此，杀害罗莎·卢森堡和其他被称为斯巴达克同盟的柏林左翼人士，并且他们
Very Robespierre-ish. Very Robespierre behaviour, yes. So Munich is then retaken. And it's retaken by a group who a lot of people say anticipate the Nazis in all kinds of ways. They're called the Freikorps, the Free Corps. And these are basically returning soldiers who they've come back from the war some of them it's still in disbelief that they've lost at all and these are the same guys who are putting down the communists in berlin as well exactly right killing a razor luxembourg and other left-wing people called the spartacists in berlin and they
镇压了慕尼黑的红色共和国，而且他们是非常右翼的。他们随心所欲地枪杀人。当他们最终杀入慕尼黑时，他们大约杀害了一千名、处决了一千名共产主义者。所以慕尼黑在那整个时期，那大约六个月的时间里，一直是一个绝对的烂摊子。那么希特勒这个时候在干什么呢？我的意思是，他在做什么？
put down the red republic in um in munich and uh they are very right wing. They are shooting people out of hand. They kill about a thousand, execute about a thousand communists when they finally fight their way into Munich. So Munich in all this period, this sort of six month period has been an absolute basket case. So what is Hitler up to at this point? I mean, what's he doing?
希特勒当时还在军队里。他是一名下士，因为他曾在巴伐利亚军队服役。所以帝国的不同州都派遣了自己的军队分遣队。所以他在巴伐利亚军队。在1918年、确切地说是1919年夏天，军官们做了你在那种情况下会做的事。他们想确保他们的手下都有正确的思想，因为他们担心共产主义布尔什维克思想会在士兵中传播。
Hitler is still in the army. He's a corporal because he was in the Bavarian army. So the different states of the empire sent their own sort of contingents. So he's in the Bavarian army. And in the summer of 1918, 1919 rather, the officers do what, you know, you would do in such a situation. They want to make sure that their men all have the right ideas because they're worried that communist Bolshevik ideas are spread among the soldiers.
所以他们开始把人送到训练营去接受思想教育。他们听讲座和演讲等等。我们知道，希特勒参加了这些活动，而且他表现得非常好。我的意思是，别无他法，只能这么说。他非常热心。他喜欢这些想法。而且他发现自己很有演讲天赋，对吧？
So they start to send people to sort of training camps and for instruction. They listen to lectures and speeches and so on. Hitler, we know, goes to these and he's very good. I mean, there's no other way of putting it. He's very keen. He likes the ideas. And he finds that he has a talent for public speaking, right?
这就是他发现自己对煽动民众有着这种邪恶天赋的时刻，基本上是这样。所以他基本上一直坐在讲座里回答问题，做他们所做的任何事，毫无疑问还参加了分组讨论。上级说：“他真的很棒。我们让他去做一些演讲吧。”他在1919年8月开始这样做。他们再次表示，他非常，
This is the moment where he discovers that he has this kind of malign genius for rabble-rousing, basically. Yeah. So he's basically been sitting in the lectures and answering questions and doing whatever they do, breaking for group discussions, no doubt. And the superiors say, he's really good. We'll get him to give some of the lectures. He starts doing it in August, 1919. And again, they say he's very,
非常擅长与士兵们交谈，因为他是他们中的一员，所以他能跟他们对话。他用简单、朴实、直接的语言交流。他因战败而充满苦涩。他痛恨左翼、共产主义者等等。他痛恨犹太人。所以他在这个阶段的反犹太主义非常非常明显。当时有一封著名的信，他在信中谈到了种族结核病。所以，又是那种疾病的概念。
very good at talking to the men because he talks to the men because he's one of them. He talks in simple, earthy, direct language. He's burning with bitterness about defeat. He hates the left, the communists and so on. He hates the Jews. So his anti-Semitism is very, very pronounced at this stage. There's a famous letter from this time where he's talking, he describes the racial tuberculosis. So again, it's that idea of disease.
那种医学语言，完全正确。所以他找到了自己的声音。这个无名小卒找到了某种东西。他唯一擅长的事情，基本上就是对听他说话的士兵群体进行咆哮和狂热宣泄。现在，他的上级决定在此基础上进一步培养他。彻底的政治混乱。有几十个不同的政党，极左、极右、古怪的、极端的，各种各样。其中有一个党叫德国工人党。这是由一个叫安东·德莱克斯勒的锁匠于1919年1月创立的。它是某个会让你感兴趣的事物的衍生品，汤姆。我会称之为图勒学会，但你大概会认为是图勒。图勒。终极图勒，对罗马人来说是极北之地的冰冷土地，也就是冰岛之类的地方。
That medical language, exactly. So he's found a voice. This nobody has found something. The one thing he's very good at, which is basically ranting and raving to groups of soldiers who listen. Now, his superiors decide to build on that. total political chaos. There are dozens and dozens of different political parties, far left, far right, cranky, extreme, all sorts. One of them is a party called the German Workers' Party. And this had been founded in January 1919 by a locksmith called Anton Drexler. And it's an outgrowth of something that will interest you, Tom. I would call it the Thule Society, but you would, I imagine it's Thule. Thule. Ultima Thule, which for the Romans was the icy land in the farthest
是的。所以这是一个微小的、极右翼的大德意志集团，但它也非常反犹太。所以他们也对神秘主义之类的事情非常热衷，不是吗？是的，他们是的。而且他们非常热衷于雅利安人的那一套，不是吗？是的，他们是的。而且他们
north, so Iceland or whatever. Yeah. So this is a kind of tiny, hard-right pan-German group, but it's also very anti-Semitic. So they're also really into the occult and stuff, aren't they? They are, yes. And also they're very into the idea of Arian stuff aren't they they are yes yes and also they um
非常热衷于雅利安主义的思想，所以他们使用万字旗——一种古老的印度符号——作为雅利安人的象征。所以这些暗流汹涌，他们由一个被定罪的伪造者、诈骗犯领导，他冒充男爵。哦，对。图勒学会。是的。所以这一切……而且它叫图勒，因为它是最北端。所以这是关于北欧人种的概念，所有这些乱七八糟的东西。
they're very into the idea of of arianism and so they use the swastika which is kind of ancient indian symbol as a symbol for for the arians so that's kind of bubbling away and they're led by this convicted forger fraudster who is passing himself off as a baron. Oh, right. The Thule Society. Yeah. So it's all... And it's Thule because it's the furthest north. So it's this idea of a Nordic race, all that kind of stuff.
是的。所以德国工人党是这个叫德莱克斯勒的家伙衍生出来的产物。它兜售着那些在1880年代、1890年代流传的大德意志主义、民族主义、反犹太主义的思想，它的目标人群是中下阶层的人，它实际上非常非常小。在慕尼黑这并不罕见。它是众多此类政党之一。
Yeah. So the German Workers' Party is a kind of slight spin-off of this by this guy, Drexler. It's selling all those ideas that were floating around in the 1880s 1890s kind of pan germanism nationalism anti-semitism it's aimed at kind of lower middle class people it is actually very very small it's nothing unusual in munich it's one of many such parties
希特勒被他的上司——一个叫卡尔·迈尔的队长，他后来其实非常痛恨希特勒，并在二战中丧生——派了过去。迈尔说：“去看看这些人在搞什么名堂。”所以希特勒进去了。有个小型会议。在问答环节，有人站起来说：“我认为巴伐利亚应该脱离德国其余部分，成为一个独立国家。”
and hitler was sent by his um his captain a guy called Karl Mayr, who actually later completely hated Hitler and ended up being killed in the Second World War. Mayr says, go along and see what's going on with these guys. So Hitler goes in. There's this little meeting. In the Q&A, somebody gets up and says, I think Bavaria should break away from the rest of Germany and become its own country.
希特勒跳了起来，开始大喊大叫，并说：“我认为巴伐利亚应该脱离德国其余部分，成为一个独立国家。”希特勒跳了起来，开始大喊大叫，并说：“这是一个可怕的想法，”你知道的，狂怒咆哮。然后——这非常像推特。对吧。我想是的。德莱克斯勒对他说：“你知道的，你非常——年轻人，我对你印象深刻，你知道吗，为什么不，我们非常希望你加入。”希特勒加入了。他成为了555号成员。现在，
Hitler jumps to his feet and just starts shouting and says, I think Bavaria should break away from the rest of Germany and become its own country. Hitler jumps to his feet and just starts shouting and says, this is a terrible idea, you know, ranting and raving. And afterwards- It's very like Twitter. Right. I guess so. Drexler says to him, you know, you're very, I was impressed by you, young man, you know, why don't you, we'd love you to join. And Hitler joins. He becomes member 555. Now,
他们绝对没有超过500名成员。可能他们有55名成员，但他们会给出……你知道的，他们会给人一种他们比实际规模更大的印象，把人数充大。他去参加了更多的会议。军队似乎鼓励他继续去。他们说：“你知道的，太棒了。他们喜欢你这样做。继续去。盯着他们。你知道，也许我们可以利用他们。我们可以随时关注他们。”太棒了。
they definitely didn't have more than 500 members. Probably they had 55 members, but they would put the, you know, they would sort of give the impression they were bigger than they were, pad it out. He goes to more meetings. It seems probable that the army encouraged him to keep going. They said, you know, oh, great. They like you at this. Keep going. Keep an eye on them. You know, maybe we can use them. You know, we can keep tabs on them. Brilliant.
你继续露面。所以希特勒去了，并向他们发表演讲，成了他们的王牌演说家。我的意思是，他们并不是一个才华横溢的组织。所以你可能会说这并不是很难。小池塘里的大鱼。是的。但毫无疑问他在这方面非常擅长。1919年变成了1920年。会议越开越大。大型集会和啤酒馆之类的场所。如果你读伊恩·克肖和理查德·埃文斯的描述，他们会让人明白，对我们来说很容易说，
You keep turning up. So Hitler goes and he gives speeches at them and he becomes their star speaker. I mean, they're not a highly talented outfit. So you might say that's not very difficult. Big fish in a small pond. Yeah. But there's no doubt he's very good at it. And 1919 becomes 1920. The meetings get bigger and bigger and bigger. And mass meetings and kind of beer halls and things. If you read the descriptions by Ian Kershaw and Richard Evans, they make it clear that it's easy for us to say,
这些都是怪人和狂热分子，很容易把他们争取过来。但他确实非常擅长。正如埃文斯所说，他使用普通人能听懂的简单、直接的语言，简短的句子，强有力的情感口号。他会先安静地讲以吸引大家的注意，然后声音越来越大，最后陷入一种身体上的狂热，流汗并大喊大叫。这就是信息的简单性和绝对性。没有一丝怀疑，没有一丝细微差别。你知道的，他热爱德国。
these are sort of weirdos and cranks, and it's easy to win them over. But he is very good at it. He gives these, as Evan says, he uses simple, straightforward language that ordinary people can understand, short sentences, powerful emotive slogans. He will start quietly to get people's attention, and then he'll get louder and louder, and he'll work himself into a physical frenzy, kind of sweating and shouting. And it's the sort of simplicity and the absolutism of the message. No hint of doubt, no hint of nuance. You know, he loves Germany.
正是犹太人对所发生的一切错误负有责任。德国面临的危机如此复杂，如此可怕。这是一团如此复杂的乱麻，以至于我猜，对于正在发生的事情给出非常严厉、简单的解释有着显而易见的吸引力。当然有，是的。我的意思是，想象一下。我经常思考这个问题。在爱德华时代当一个德国人——我们称之为爱德华时代——
It's the Jews who are responsible for everything that has gone wrong. And the crisis facing Germany is so complex, is so terrible. It's such a snarl of complexities that I guess very stark, simple explanations for what is going on have an obvious appeal. Of course they do, yeah. I mean, imagine that. I've often thought about this. To be German in the Edwardian, what we would call the Edwardian period,
是很棒的。你知道的，你的国家是从无到有发展起来的，是欧洲的动力源泉。令人惊叹的文化、大学、科学、工业。然后你卷入了这场你认为——我的意思是，许多历史学家可能认为这是德国的错，但德国人自己并不这么认为——你卷入了这场战争，生活却分崩离析了。突然之间你到了1919年，德皇下台了，你所相信的一切都被颠倒了，陷入了绝对彻底的混乱之中。当然，你在寻找艺术家。我想这是埃文斯，理查德·埃文斯谈到了他所说的希特勒集会的复兴式狂热，在这样动荡的时代，你完全可以理解为什么那些觉得自己正在受苦、受辱的人会抓住一个提供救赎和替罪羊的信息。实际上，是的，因为反犹太主义的东西从一开始就在那里，有趣的是，我也感到相当惊讶。所以回想我那糟糕的GCSE历史课——顺便说一句，戈西先生是一位极好的老师，但我显然完全
was great. You know, your country had come from nowhere and was the dynamo of Europe. Amazing culture, universities, science, industry. And then you go into this war that you don't think, I mean, lots of historians may think it's Germany's fault fault but the germans themselves don't you go into this war and life just falls apart and suddenly you're in 1919 the kaiser is gone the everything that you believed in has been turned upside down is in an absolute and utter chaos and of course you're looking for artists and i think it's evans richard evans talks about what he calls the revivalist fervor of Hitler's meetings, and in such traumatic times, you can absolutely see why people who feel themselves to be suffering and to be humiliated would grasp a message offering salvation and offering scapegoats actually yeah because the jewish the anti-jewish stuff is right there from the beginning interestingly and i was quite surprised um so thinking back to my my terrible gcse history i mean the teacher by the way mr gorsy was excellent but i but i clearly had completely
误解了，因为我一直认为反马克思主义对希特勒来说至关重要。但伊恩·克肖和理查德·埃文斯都说不，他其实并不是在谈论反马克思主义对希特勒至关重要。但伊恩·克肖和理查德·埃文斯都说不。他当时并没有真正谈论马克思主义或布尔什维克主义。他一直在谈论的是犹太人。所以反布尔什维克主义是后来才出现的。但这说得通，不是吗？因为反马克思主义将是参与整个欧洲几十年来一直很熟悉的传统政治辩论的一部分。嗯，实际上，自从法国大革命以来，你几乎可以说。但把犹太人指认为问题所在，则是在以一种次达尔文主义的模式说话，而这种模式也许人们以前并没有。
misunderstood because i always thought that anti-marxism was so key to hitler but both uh in kershaw and richard evans say no he doesn't really talk about marxism was so key to Hitler. But both Ian Kershaw and Richard Evans say no. He doesn't really talk about Marxism at this point or Bolshevism. What he's talking about all the time are the Jews. So the anti-Bolshevism comes later. But that makes sense, doesn't it? Because to be anti-Marxist would be to be part of a conventional political debate of a kind that is familiar across Europe and has been for decades. Well, really, since the French Revolution, you might almost say. But to identify the Jews as the problem is to be talking in a kind of sub-Darwinian mode that perhaps people hadn't
存在误解，因为我一直认为反马克思主义对希特勒来说至关重要，但伊恩·克肖和理查德·埃文斯都认为并非如此。此时他并没有怎么谈论马克思主义或布尔什维克主义。他一直在谈论的是犹太人。所以反布尔什维克主义是后来才出现的。但这很合理，不是吗？因为反马克思主义就等于参与了一种在整个欧洲延续了几十年、人们早已司空见惯的常规政治辩论。好吧，几乎可以说从法国大革命以来就是如此。但将犹太人确定为问题所在，则是用一种类似于次达尔文主义的模式在说话，这种模式也许人们以前并未
realized before, that the blood is all, and that therefore, if the blood gets infected then disaster happens it's a new radical explanation that people in the mood to accept it are going to accept and actually another thing tom though is um it's the violence of it we did the podcast about auschwitz the question that hangs over all this is at what point is the final solution on the table? I mean, Hitler is saying in April 1920, the Jews are to be exterminated. In August 1920, you shouldn't think that you can fight a disease without killing the cause. Without annihilating the bacillus, you won't be able to get rid of the racial tuberculosis. April 1921, the solution of the Jewish question can only be solved by brute force. So all of those ideas are there at this stage. I mean, what the thing is, though, so Hitler has cronies at this point.
以前没有意识到，血代表了一切，因此如果血液受到感染，灾难就会发生。这是一种全新的、激进的解释，那些愿意接受这种情绪的人会去接受它。汤姆，实际上还有一件事，那就是其中的暴力色彩。我们做过一期关于奥斯威辛的播客，悬在这一切之上的问题是：最终解决方案在什么时候被提上日程？我的意思是，希特勒在1920年4月就说过，犹太人必须被消灭。1920年8月，你不应该认为在不杀死病因的情况下能够战不战胜疾病。不消灭杆菌，你就无法摆脱种族结核病。1921年4月，犹太人问题的解决只能通过残酷的武力来解决。所以所有这些想法在这个阶段都已经存在了。我的意思是，关键在于，此时希特勒有了一帮亲信。
By 1921, he has control of the Nazi Party. There are various internal shenanigans. He's threatened to walk out. So when does it become the Nazi Party? When's that name change happened? So it goes from the German Workers' Party to the National Socialist German Workers' Party in February 1920. And Hitler also designs the flag.
到1921年，他已经控制了纳粹党。期间发生了各种内部权力斗争，他曾威胁要退党。那么它是什么时候变成纳粹党的呢？那个名字是什么时候改的？在1920年2月，它从德国工人党改名为国家社会主义德国工人党（即纳粹党），希特勒还设计了党旗。
So the swastika, that comes from the Thule. Thule Society. Thule Society. The colours, black, white, red, they are are the imperial colors they're the colors of the kaiser's right so you can see there's a reactionary element but there's also the kind of slightly cranky occultist element very cranky with the with the swastika exactly um so he lives in charge really by the summer of 1921 he's threatened to walk out and he's been made the big man in the party. He has started to get a group of
所以纳粹党旗上的卐字标志，源自图勒会。图勒会。至于黑色、白色、红色的配色，它们是帝国的颜色，是德皇的颜色，所以你可以看到其中既有反动元素，也有那种略带古怪的神秘主义元素，用卐字标志真的很古怪。确切地说，到1921年夏天，他真正掌权了，他威胁要退党，并成为了党内的绝对领袖。他开始拥有一群
cronies, some very recognisable names. So Hans Frank, his lawyer, you mentioned before, Rudolf Hess. So they're both in the Thule society, aren't they? They're both in the Thule society. A guy called Julius Streicher, he comes in from Nuremberg. He becomes the, he's an
心腹，其中有一些非常熟悉的名字。比如他的律师汉斯·弗兰克，你刚才提到的鲁道夫·赫斯。所以他们两个都是图勒会的成员，对吧？他们都是图勒会的成员。还有一个叫朱利叶斯·施特莱歇尔的人，他从纽伦堡加入进来。他成了
absolutely obsessive anti-Semite. He edits Der Stürmer, the famous anti-Semitic newspaper. He's a key figure because he's going to reach out to Protestants as well as the sort of Catholic population of Bavaria. Hermann Goering. Yeah. He comes in, he's an air ace. He'd flown with the Red Baron.
一个极端狂热的反犹太主义者。他编辑著名的反犹报纸《冲锋报》。他是一个关键人物，因为他不仅能接触到巴伐利亚的天主教徒，还能接触到新教徒。赫尔曼·戈林。是的。他加入进来时是一名王牌飞行员，曾与红男爵并肩作战。
He had, well, he'd ended up becoming the commander of the Red Baron's flying circus at the very end of the war. He's amazingly, given his sort of corpulence later in life, he's seen as this great dashing romantic figure in the 1920s. So a bit of a coup for the Nazis to get him. And there's another anti-Semichot, Alfred Rosenberg, who is fanatically anti-Christian. So one for you, Tom. Rosenberg has plans to replace all crosses in Germany with swastikas and to replace all copies of the Bible with Mein Kampf.
他，嗯，他在战争快结束时最终成为了红男爵飞行马戏团的指挥官。考虑到他晚年发福的体型，令人惊讶的是，在20世纪20年代，他被视为一个风流倜傥的浪漫人物。因此，纳粹能拉拢他算是一次相当大的成功。还有另一个反犹太主义狂热分子阿尔弗雷德·罗森堡，他狂热地反基督教。所以，汤姆，这一个是给你的。罗森堡计划用卐字标志取代德国所有的十字架，并用《我的奋斗》取代所有的《圣经》。
Yeah. Well, he's ahead of Hitler there. Yeah, he is indeed. Who for much of the 20s is proclaiming the Nazis are very Christian. Yeah. But he can see more clearly that that isn't the case. I mean, they're not friends I would personally choose to have. No.
是的。嗯，在这方面他比希特勒走得更前面。是的，他确实如此。在20世纪20年代的大部分时间里，希特勒都在宣称纳粹非常基督教化。是的。但他能更清楚地看到事实并非如此。我的意思是，这些朋友我个人是绝对不会选择去交的。没有。
But they're hanging around with Hitler in the early 1920s. So it's a small party, but it's growing. Now, here's the funny thing as we look forward to the next episode. All the ingredients are there. So you've got all the themes, the Lebensraum, the pan-Germanism, the search for scapegoats, the hatred of the Treaty of Versailles that has settled the end of the First World War, the hatred of the so-called November criminals, all of that stuff.
但他们在20世纪20年代初就和希特勒混在一起。所以它是一个小党，但它在不断壮大。现在，当我们展望下一集时，有趣的地方来了。所有的成分都已经具备了。所以你拥有了所有的主题：生存空间、大日耳曼主义、寻找替罪羊、对敲定第一次世界大战结局的《凡尔赛条约》的仇恨，对所谓的十一月罪犯的仇恨，所有这些东西。
The violence, the speeches, all of that is there. But the one thing that's not there is that at this point, Hitler does not see himself as a future leader of Germany. As Ian Kershaw puts it, Hitler sees himself as merely the drummer. He is the propagandist. He is the John the Baptist who is paving the way for the Messiah who one day will lead this German national movement to greatness. But that, of course, will change.
暴力、演讲，所有这些都具备了。但唯一没有具备的是，在此时，希特勒并不认为自己是德国未来的领袖。正如伊恩·克肖所说，希特勒认为自己只是敲鼓手。他是宣传家。他是为有朝一日将这个德意志民族运动引向伟大的弥赛亚铺平道路的施洗约翰。但当然，这将会改变。
And I guess we'll have to wait until next time, Tom, to discover how and why. And, of course, if you're a member of the Restless History Club, you can listen to that right now. Don't need to wait. Pile straight in. Don't need to wait at all. The Weimar Republic awaits.
我想我们得等到下一次，汤姆，去发现它是如何以及为何改变的。当然，如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的会员，你现在就可以收听了。不需要等待。直接开听。完全不需要等待。魏玛共和国在等着你。
But if you're not, you will have to wait until Thursday for Weimar. And I guess we will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
但如果你还不是会员，你将不得不等到周四才能收听关于魏玛的内容，我想我们到时候见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。